good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Thursday hey Jax
how you doing I'm turnka cause you were
just gracing us with a performance I
said you should save it for the show
because it was sounding so good because
I was telling strike Sands right here
how much I love him oh my man I love you
so you'll never know you'll never know
and that is actually one of my like new
favorite songs I have like a repertoire
of like four or five songs that I know I
can sing well like karaoke
um and that one has recently made its
way into the top five my man from the
screen version of funny girl
unfortunately not the stage version and
it's such a song I actually sing it to
Harry quite a bit because he's my man I
love him so he'll never know all my life
is just to spare but I don't care when
he takes me in his arms the world is
bright all right foreign
that's literally how I feel about Harry
that's beautiful oh my God and the
Brethren of course of course like me and
Harry had such a day yesterday it's such
a pleasure to be in the same house as
him it's like you really don't mind
getting up in the morning yeah because
you know there's like a big face waiting
no it's like getting out of bed is tough
brushing your teeth walking down the
hall but the minute you get in there no
is right like by the way which is
something I would never do in my own
house I am like up in Harry's room
before I brush my teeth and before I
check my phone yeah before I check my
phone
um sometimes I have to pee but I usually
try and brush my teeth because then once
I'm in there like I don't know the next
time I'm going back to my room and like
yeah what if I want to have breakfast
like it was just an amazing day of being
in the same house to things in the same
house as Harry like it's not
I feel like maybe it's something like
you might take for granted because you
like live here but to be not only like
in the same house his next door neighbor
it's such a privilege yeah and I don't
even mind when he wakes me up you know
it's a delight um I was though like
tossing and turning all night I just my
mind was elsewhere because we right
before bed decided to do the dumbest
thing ever and watch the first and last
episodes of catching Kelsey the reality
show starring Super Bowl hopeful Travis
Kelsey I had never seen it Jackie was
like it's really good when I tell you I
bought the whole season for 13 I had
every intention to like watch it it was
so
dumb like it wasn't bad I was just like
actively losing brain cells and the
girls were moronic Travis was more on it
like it was so it was honestly atrocious
and I really did like I wanted to see
who won and I watched the first episode
and then we watched the second episode
and I just skipped to the end I was
shocked like last episode we were like
we'll watch it first and then she didn't
want to watch more I was like okay but
we have to watch the last we turned on
the last she couldn't even watch that so
we just skipped to the last five minutes
and she was genuinely shocked at who won
even when I came in you were watching
the first episode and I was looking and
I remember a lot of the people and I
couldn't I didn't see the person who won
I was like am I misremembering it was
literally 20 minutes into the episode
that they even showed her like I know
throughout the season she became more
relevant especially in like house drama
but like there were 20 girls there and
we did not see her for 20 minutes no and
like the show was obviously like
mirroring The Bachelor in a lot of ways
because I think a lot of you know dating
shows did at the time and the way the
show just made no sense I'm glad I
didn't waste my time because we
literally watched episode where Travis
singled out a girl and said she was the
hottest girl in the house like 100 his
type he there was nobody more hot and
she went home the first episode and like
of course maybe not the hottest girl
wins because like you develop
connections but the hottest girl makes
it past week one like he just lacked
logic it was it was literally like one
of the dumbest things I'd ever seen and
I got a lot of messages when I posted
that we were watching it of people who
like you know um like new girls going on
the show they said it was so fraudulent
like Travis was like hooking up with a
bunch of the girls like it was not real
it was completely scripted like it was
so fake so honestly if I'd wasted
there's seven episodes seven hours
actually eight because the last episode
was two hours if I had wasted eight
hours I would have been so annoyed but
now I feel like I got the gist of the
show and now when we reference it
literally every day on the show I feel
like I know a little bit of what I'm
talking about yeah you are definitely
missing out it's definitely like it was
a cultural ship for sure no it wasn't it
actually I watched it when it aired and
it was really it was something special
he's a cutie he's a cutie the brother
brother is on the show too you get a
sense of like their personalities plus
because of their podcast you also get a
sense there's a story about them today
okay their podcast is number one overall
in the App Store deservedly so no I love
this moment for podcasting yeah because
all we have is this moment and for
Brethren yeah and for families yeah and
I'm glad that they're not letting this
really come between them yeah and we can
all just like appreciate the moment of
the Kelsey Bowl yeah the Kelsey ball
um also I guess we'll talk about them
when we talk about them but like Jason's
kind of like
coming up as the superior brother let's
let's wait okay because I have thoughts
too
um but today's also just like a fabulous
special episode because of course you
girls are back together together again
in front of the flamingos yada Brethren
are in studio but we have a very special
interview so I was like being really
annoying when I was in LA like secret
interview secret project the first one
was obviously Jay Shetty and now the
second one is airing it is Taylor
Lautner and his wife Taylor Lautner
um they just launched a podcast so they
wanted to come on talk about their
podcast of course like I had to go deep
on um the Twilight of it all and
honestly I was so
obsessed with talking about Twilight
because people are like please tell me
you ask them about like Back to December
when I tell you I forgot like and I feel
bad and like I was like kind of annoyed
at myself last night I'm like how did I
literally forget and I had a question
like a really funny question the way I
would phrase it like I had it rehearsed
in my mind I was gonna be like Taylor do
you sleep amazing at night he's gonna be
like I guess what like what do you mean
let's role play okay okay so I'm
thinking about to go into an ad but I
know what you're gonna say no it's not
an ad no I'm saying but that sounds like
what you're about to say okay Taylor do
you sleep amazing at night I'm just
curious
actually I have sleep apnea oh I just
figured you would you know sleep so
restfully unlike the other men in
Hollywood who are just quaking every
night wondering what songs from The
Vault are going to come out and knowing
if there's one about you it's probably
so nice and I totally forgot to talk
about Taylor like I'm so dumb but I feel
really good about the interview because
I focus a lot on Twilight and like
that's for me like that's that actually
was a cultural Global seismic shift of
course so we talked about that we talked
about like his journey with mental
health his like comeuppance to fame
Sharkboy and Lava Girl I forget like he
was in so many iconic things like
Cheaper by the Dozen two he was in like
that rival family with Eugene Levy and
um Valentine's Day like he really he has
this like illustrious career and it was
a really good interview so if you're
watching on YouTube it'll be at the end
of this video if you're watching as a
podcast it'll be at the end of the
podcast and I hope you enjoy it they're
so sweet and they just got married
the show you reference all the time and
I watched the first episode and like I
don't it's not one of my personal
references you know what I mean you're
missing out and one day you'll binge it
and you'll say you Coulda Shoulda Woulda
yeah it's so good and they keep saying
it's coming back I feel like that's one
of the things like they're always saying
like the Hilary Duff reboot I mean the
Lizzie McGuire no but that was being
rebooted and then it ended like there
was action there it's like Legally
Blonde four but it is happening right
but no like scream Queens like no one's
heard anything since someone said it was
coming back yeah
um such as not like a reference in my
portfolio of references you're missing
out like everyone's there everyone Glenn
Powell Glenn Powell Jonas Leah Michelle
Kirstie Alley Jerry O'Connor yeah [__]
now like that's something that'll get me
to watch it yeah you take a Keke Palmer
on the toast do your thing I know but
she's like pregnant now and she's like
at the final like it'll be it'll be
we'll have to wait don't put the ask out
until she's back from Germany leave
um so we've got a great show the stories
are you said light they're they're light
they're you know very uh like Morning
Show we're such a morning we're going
back to Our Roots learning show the
morning toast yeah when we re-roost when
we rebranded we should have went from
the morning toast to the Marling toast I
totally agree I'll be changed one letter
one letter honestly how did we not think
of that because we're stupid we're so
dumb and we're con I think we're getting
Dumber you know no I like it's like
we're dumb and we're getting Dumber but
we're all so smart and we're getting
smarter so [__] true like honestly
nobody is smarter than us literally but
nobody's also dumber than us too
literally literally no like compared to
how dumb some people are we're not that
dumb that's true that's true but I feel
like unless you really feel like so dumb
and so smart at all times like you're
not living yeah no that's like a famous
quote like from a philosopher like like
dumb people like intelligent people
question their thinking all the time
okay so dumb people are like yum right
that's
[Music]
say that don't forget the accent yeah
yeah I'm always right that's true like
dumb people are always wrong
um which is that they feel so right it's
okay to be wrong but it's like the
they're so indignant in their room they
don't question their premises
intelligent people are constantly
questioning whether or not they're right
it's so important to constantly be
asking questions which we are I'm
questioning everything everything
everything anything the 40 is still
sitting there but I have a plan for it
today because we're going to Target okay
and if you like we're gonna get lots of
work that could be our lunch we're gonna
put it to work yeah
can't wait I'm ready for lunch so early
I had my breakfast earlier than usual
this morning and so now I'm ready for
lunch there's really not a day that goes
by where I don't wake up and like and
I'm not immediately thinking about lunch
yeah because I don't really eat
breakfast I've started eating like a
nice like balanced breakfast of just
like some yogurt granola and fruit which
is really tasty not very fiddling no and
I've been watching Ginny and George I'm
about to finish the first season and
they have like a breakfast every morning
like with like a set tables and like
whatever it is like eggs but it's like
there's a set table like a pitcher of
juice and it really looks so nice you
know what maybe this weekend we'll do
one big breakfast mornings my friends
are coming it's gonna be like a really
pop-in weekend so we'll make like eggs
maybe some french toast pancakes we'll
have to get all the ingredients when we
go to this tour today yeah no um look
that's something definitely like I want
for my future I feel like you know when
your kids start going to school like you
have to have like a breakfast in the
morning so that's when you start
implementing like it's still it's like
in Eggo still but it's something yeah
but it's not you know fresh made eggs
and
I would prefer an ego over a fresh made
egg no eggs are so good I think this is
Anime if you can get such a privilege
you saw that egg fire what like a farm
um an egg Farm went up in Flames
mysteriously a hundred thousand chickens
oh my God
oh my cover ball um seriously
mysteriously accidentally
hmm
hmm makes you think no such thing as an
accident
you know what I'm saying
um
well cool should we Dive In
I think so where stray said he's ready
even though he's been a traitor ready
for what ready for the past five stories
that he needs to know before he wakes up
and has his mining kibble today's
episode is brought to you by Clinique
Clinique's multivitamin of makeup
because Clinique Even Better clinical
serum Foundation is a once a day
foundation it's formulated with three
serum technologies that visibly reduce
dark spots brighten and hydrate skin
once a day every day for even better
looking skin
um I just got a refill because I've used
mine up completely it is the best
foundation first of all just like in
terms of makeup like coverage it's
really really beautiful it lays so nice
on your skin it's buildable so if you
want like a sheer coverage or you want
more full coverage but I feel like
whenever I used to wear foundations it
would like clog my pores and at the end
of the day I'd be like red and just have
all these different issues with my skin
but because the Clinique Foundation is
made with skin care it has three serums
built into it I like have a visible
difference in my skin when I take my
makeup off it's not like my makeup has
been through battle all day and my skin
has been through battle all day and now
I'm finally taking it off it's like
actively working to just mellow my skin
out and in as little as eight weeks your
skin appears even more toned more
radiant and smoother even after your
makeup is removed calling if it a
foundation does not do it justice it is
a clinical Foundation because it's built
with three serum Technologies it's a
hydrating formula it provides 24-hour
full coverage it has a matte finish it
has a lightweight texture a 24 hour
color true where it is oil free
waterproof sweat and humidity resistant
it's non-acnegenic non-caking
non-settling non-creasing non-poring and
non-streaking it's a really really
beautiful finish on your skin so your
makeup will look great nothing will
change like you'll still look snatched
but you just know like the foundation
that's laying on your skin is not
actively working against you it's
hydrating it has serums in it it's made
with skin care the package is is really
beautiful but it's also sustainable so
every glass bottle of the even better
clinical serum Foundation can be
recycled you just remove the cap and the
pump you'll rinse the glass bottle and
then you'll place that in the recycling
bin
um it's available in 42 Shades the shade
matcher online works so well I got
literally a perfect shade match you can
find your shade with the Clinique
clinical ready shade match science it's
a virtual try on it works really well
just once a day for even better looking
bare skin shop the Clinique Even Better
clinical serum Foundation this
Valentine's Day for 20 off you can use a
discount
um on their website it's valid through
Valentine's day you'll find your shade
at clinique.com and that's the Clinique
Even Better clinical serum Foundation
it's 20 off through Valentine's Day
um at clinique.com so check that out
today's episode is also brought to you
by stamps.com it's the post office
elevated the postage rates in general
excuse me just increased again but
luckily stamps.com has the best
discounts in the industry we are always
using stamps.com if you like since
Jackie moved we're probably using it
even more sending like merch samples
back to each other things and honestly
there's no hell of Greater on Earth than
going to the post office but thanks to
stamps.com you don't have to because you
get all the USPS shipping rates Ups Too
you get all that access at your home you
can print postage ship anything any size
anywhere
they have been an indispensable
resources for over a million businesses
including the toast you can print
postage wherever you do your business
basically all you need is a computer and
a printer
um they'll even send you a free scale so
you have everything you need to get
started we love stamps.com it has been
such a lifesaver one thing about us
we're not going to leave our houses you
know and stamps.com is making that easy
you can get a four week trial free
postage and a digital scale when you go
to stamps.com toast thanks to stamps.com
for sponsoring Today's Show again that's
stamps.com toast for a four week trial
free postage and a digital scale
thank you turdy you're welcome just want
to say yes a hundred thousand chickens
burned in the connected fire and then I
I was just searching chicken farm fire
and in December 250
000 chickens burned in Florida chicken
farm someone's coming for the chickens
quarter of a million someone so it's
going to be the chicken 100k
someone's coming for the chickens
protect our chickens
you know who else they're coming for
it's rice Punxsutawney Phil as they
should because yesterday or today
today is Groundhog's Day 2023 and
Punxsutawney Phil predicted six more
weeks of winter does he ever not like my
God he's so negative so unpopular and
it's like pucks if you just said it was
gonna be less no one would hold you to
it no he's so negative I don't believe
in like groundhog saying I feel like I'm
actually having like Groundhog's Day
right now because I feel like we have
this conversation every single year as
we do we need to acknowledge Groundhog's
Day because it's just a [__] sweet no
it's just a sweet tradition like if all
these guys dress up like Colonial men
and it's just [__] funny and like I
can't believe it still happens I can't
believe it still happens too especially
after you know the kind of Scandal a few
years ago where Bill de Blasio actually
dropped Punxsutawney and killed him and
then they like covered it up at the zoo
um so I hope the new mayor is like
having more respect for animals
yeah
um and this is what I say every year and
like I can never remember the answer is
groundhog say like an East Coast thing
is it a global thing is it a Nationwide
thing like who abides by or is it you
know what I mean I think it's the nation
they can't imagine other countries
caring about Punxsutawney yeah
um but I feel like as a nation this is
national news People magazine
everybody's talking about what he saw
what he didn't see and I know I asked
this question again every year but like
so it says six more weeks of winter but
like on the calendar when does winter
end
March March 21st that's every year does
Punxsutawney change that like no no no
no no no okay so what's the point he's a
winter weather
oh of winter weather okay okay so easy
but like I just feel like if in six
weeks it was still cold and he had said
you know it was going to be warmer soon
like we want to be mad instead like
today we'd be happy right and then in
six weeks we'd be like oh it's cold no
it's just interesting how there's really
like no accountability for Punxsutawney
and I think we live in like
accountability culture but I feel like
no I feel like that's because of the
accountability culture that's why he
always says it's going to be winter
weather because he doesn't want to get
it wrong and piss people off like I feel
like I might die before he actually
doesn't see his shadow you know or does
see his shadow it's confusing had he not
seen his shadow in early spring would
have been predicted so he saw let me
tell you how that makes no sense that
makes no sense because you See Your
Shadow in the sun when there's Sun so I
have flawed I found flaw with the whole
concept yeah but the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration
previously reported that those
predictions pan out just 40 of the time
so he's on par with meteorologists
everywhere right that's the thing
there's like really no accountability in
you know the weather condition yeah and
it's like meteorologies allegedly like
this huge science like it's it's not
like they're just guessing like they
have like radar right they have and yet
they're always strong I just find that
and there's no accountability for the
human so for me if I'm gonna be holding
whether people accountable I'm gonna
start at The Human Side level and then
when I'm done with all of them maybe
I'll get to Punxsutawney Phil speaking
of accountability do we have a story or
can we talk about it now that Michaela
made a return it's not a story because
she didn't say anything I know but we
need to at least talk about how this
story has finally come full circle
because Michaela after like a going
radio silent for a week after the whole
mascara lash we talked about it last
week if you don't know what we're
talking about go find the episode called
lash gate
um she has returned with a big nothing
Burger she just like went back to her
regular content she didn't feed the
trolls which
which like I love for her but like I did
want like some drama you know like I
wanted yeah and like we like I wanted
resolution like were you wearing them
and also it's like it just felt
a little wrong because I don't feel like
she's one of those people who don't who
doesn't care about all this drama so it
just felt like it was hovering as
opposed to it being someone else who's
like I'm not giving this air you know
it's we know just basically she shares
so much we know she's not like an
unbothered Queen like she's actually
very easily bothered so to act like this
wasn't you know didn't phase you at all
like we know that's not true yeah I just
really I wanted to get like a resolution
but I don't think Michaela lied you
don't I don't think Michaela lied I
don't think people died I actually know
for a fact that nobody died and it's so
important to remember that chickens died
yeah and we should be talking about that
Michaela didn't lie I don't think you
think you're standing by like you did it
was a filter I'm standing by that I
think it was a filter there for when she
said no lash was used it wasn't a lie
and she doesn't need to get into the
semantics of it but she can sleep at
night knowing she's not a liar okay
that's fair I mean we'll never know
because she didn't tell us but whatever
so I that's my prediction
because if she lied she'd be like eating
herself up yeah I guess and she'd feel
the need to say something you know it's
like guilty it eats you up heavy is the
head heavy as the head where's the guilt
and that's probably how Punxsutawney
feels like it's a lot of responsibility
and he's only predicted in early spring
20 times since the tradition began in
1886. oh wow sounds like there's a flaw
with this system you know the flaw is
that he doesn't want the backlash of
getting it wrong yeah so he'd rather
overestimate winter and people be
pleasantly surprised then be canceled
and you know what I can relate he's
airing kind of like Dr Phil just like
airing on the side of caution Dr
Punxsutawney Phil Dr Punxsutawney Phil
episode title they're in cahoots I love
talking about Groundhog's Day it's like
one of my favorite days of the year and
I'm like now I'm being transported to
like this cover we probably had the
exact same conversation last year but
that's the point of Groundhog's Day the
movie the same thing happens over and
over again I've actually never seen that
film have you I've seen most of it I
know the concept I don't know how they
break from the cycle of waking up on the
same day every day something crazy has
to happen yeah but I get the concept
they wake up every morning and it keeps
being the same day February 2nd
Groundhog's Day and it's just so
interesting how um like that movie and
the concept of the movie has become just
like a colloquial term yeah it's like
deja vu it's crazy
I like that yeah that's my stuff that's
why every year we have to have this
conversation I know we would be doing
our brand a d service and we'll be doing
Punxsutawney Phil like these guys they
get up in the morning so true they put
on this farce yeah at least we could do
is talk about it and they've been doing
it for over 200 years it's just less
than 200 years it's just so funny to me
like the whole concept of like you know
everyone getting dressed up going to
town hall Punxsutawney whatever it
really feels like something literally
I'm watching Jenny and George right now
and Scott Porter our favorite you know
bad actor is the mayor of this like
small town it feels like this dumb thing
like a small mayor would do but it's
like the mayor of New York City like
everyone gets involved yeah no but the
mayor of New York City is not here he
wasn't there no this isn't like a New
York City thing it's a Pennsylvania
thing
and I think yeah
I feel like the mayor was that like
always not mentioned let's search wait
so
Adam's groundhog so it's not a New York
thing why did I think that it was
because you're just like so
self-involved yeah
that does track but then there's also a
Staten Island groundhog Staten Island
chuck oh all right and that's where
mayor Adams would appear but he appeared
in a video message giving it wow the
least tell me you don't care he's doing
the least wait okay Chuck that's makes
me want to cry like talk about being
irrelevant
yeah like there's only one I feel like
every every like State tries to do their
own thing but Punxsutawney Phil is from
Phil Adelphia oh and he is the one no
he's the one and he's the only really
you know
groundhog I respect and if I'm being
honest he comes from a long line of
fills
I wonder where he lives the rest of the
year
yeah oh okay mayor Eric Adams skip
Groundhog's Day activities to attend the
funeral of an NYPD officer I'm so sorry
I take back everything back what I said
respect
well um sounds like a name as much
because it's the same thing that happens
every year yeah and it was Chuck Chuck
I'm Phil
anyways happy Groundhog's Day everyone
hope you're celebrating with someone you
love or watching the film
we're watching the film next up Jason
Kelsey says his pregnant wife Kylie is
bringing her OB GYN to the game as a
Super Bowl guest as she is 38 weeks
pregnant oh to be rich Philadelphia
Eagles Center Jason Kelsey and his
family are ready for what's being dubbed
the Kelsey Bowl speaking with his
brother Travis on their podcast the two
discussed having their family members at
the 2023 Super Bowl where the Eagles
will face off against the Kansas City
Chiefs Jason asks are Mom and Dad
sitting on your sideline are they
sitting on my sideline Travis said we do
have to figure that out because we each
get a certain amount of tickets and I
feel like you're gonna have more of a
family-oriented thing who said that
Travis right because Jason has like kids
and stuff yeah but like but then Jason
said I'm also bringing Kylie's parents
I'm bringing the girls like he might not
have enough tickets for everyone yeah he
said Kylie's bringing her OB because
she's going to be 38 weeks pregnant at
the game and then Travis was quaking
saying dude dude that could be a super
Kelsey bull if she has a baby in the
stadium no not in the stadium it's
officially scripted Travis said we're in
The Matrix there's no [__] way I'm
obsessed with these two more so now we
can dive into this conversation more so
Jason than Travis I feel like Travis
gets all the hype because he's like the
younger cuter like single single and I
think he's like sorry he's not cuter
they're both really cute but he's like
the more like Bachelor type and he's
like a little bit more in the spotlight
yeah and especially like his position on
the team so I feel like we're all like
Travis only happens to have a brother
Jason then you like get to know them and
it's like Jason's the star yeah Jason's
the star Jason's the star he's certainly
the star of the podcast oh yeah he's the
one keeping it on the tracks he's kind
of like you
totally he's you and like I'm Travis and
everyone's like oh it's like you know
Travis like we all know him but then
like you watch and you're like Travis is
annoying and like fat no kidding no but
it's like if you like had a reality show
like I would just come and support and
give you good advice no but then like if
we had a podcast which we do people
would come to the podcast be like wait
oh Jackie's the star of this show she's
got something to say yeah I actually I
see a lot of myself unfortunately in
Travis
yeah but I love that for us Travis is
such a lovable he is but like I'm
personally like I'm obsessed with Jason
like I love that his wife is still
coming no matter what with the OB
hopefully she's gonna fly that's what I
was thinking but I don't know if you
can't fly as a pregnant woman after
seven months because it's not good for
the baby or because you could
potentially go into labor it's because
of the the pressure cabin pressure could
cause like labor maybe she'll take like
an RV over the course of a week you know
she'd have to start now it's a long
drive from Philadelphia it's not like
it's in New York it's in Arizona maybe
if I listen to the whole episode I'll
get the Deeds on how she's getting there
yeah I'm curious about that too maybe
they just fly really low
yeah yeah but she's bringing the obese
she could give birth on the plane but
that's not ideal no not even close
but like I love that for her yeah I hope
she gives birth on Super Bowl night
after when the game is done so it's
actually I think people are always
surprised to learn like when you're you
know even like the wife of a player it's
like really hard to get tickets for you
and your family you get like literally
four
um that's why I really feel like a brand
needs to enter here and sponsor a box
like for the Kelsey for the Kelsey
family yeah bring in you know some of
the systems might needed if she did go
into labor right and like just kind of
have like a Kelsey cam yeah streaming on
Twitter or like Periscope you know a
brand really needs to get involved in
like buy a box for the entire Kelsey
family and just like make them you know
dance for us yeah I totally agree
they're missing an opportunity uh for
sure I'm sure some someone's working on
it and if they're not like please like
if you're listening and you like work at
a brand like don't be dumb it should be
like Heinz like an iconic Bud Light like
an iconic Super Bowl Doritos yeah
Kelsey cam brought to you by Doritos
everyone is talking about this yeah and
look for a brand to not get involved I
wonder if there's like
they could sponsor the family yeah I
wonder if there's like regulations like
you can't sponsor a player but
the family yeah and also like it's the
Kelsey but this has never happened
before right throughout the window it's
unprecedented it's out the window it's
unprecedented but we are starting to see
some like Super Bowl content yeah so
that's our next story which is so I'm
obsessed a Super Bowl commercial from
Bud Light featuring Miles Teller and
Kelly teller they are giving a sneak
peek at their home life in the new Super
Bowl ad for Bud Light where they are on
hold with customer service miles cracks
open the Bud Lights and they make a they
make the most of it they make the most
of 96 Minutes on hold dancing to hold
music oh excuse me I have to sneeze hold
on
hahaha
thank you I do feel like this was really
good marketing because I this was
definitely the year of Miles Teller but
it was also like the year of Miles
Teller and his wife like the Taylor
Swift music video Miles Teller going so
viral on Tick Tock and then Kelly
stepping in and being like move over
[__] like just he's married he's
married you know it really was the year
of the tellers so this is such like
smart marketing I loved it and it's the
concept of English marketing I think
it's marketing the concept of the
commercial is cute and stuff but just
like the idea that somebody partnered
with them genius genius huge makes me
want a bed light desperately yeah and
their dog is in the commercial too which
oh this brother and felt represented it
was beautiful for everyone you love to
see brother in representation yeah so
and also like miles teller's dance moves
have you like have had a moment this
year so we got more dancing from him it
just reminds me of his role in Footloose
which should not be overlooked Jackie
when he was doing like that little
footwork in the commercial I thought the
same thing and he definitely learned
that when he was on the set of Footloose
and the little girls were teaching him
how to dance and it's like so funny that
his role in that film is that he doesn't
know how to dance when it's like he's a
dancer known for being a dancer now yeah
yeah he's a professional dancer so
commercial really should have been set
too
no no the one where he from the Montage
where he learns how to dance let's hear
it
[Music]
let's give the boy a hey
let's hear about my baby you know you
gotta understand
it's hard to hit this up oh maybe he's
no Romeo but he's my loving one-man show
oh oh whoa whoa let's hear it for the
Bros do do
such a good song that's what the
commercial should have been to yeah I do
feel like Super Bowl commercials have
been falling off recently like it used
to be that's what you watched or maybe
that's what I watch for and now like I'm
just so into the football it's like I'll
use the commercial break to use the
restroom yeah we've kind of like a ball
we have a valve no but I do feel like
they've been really shitty cringe cringe
stupid and they're trying so hard and it
doesn't need to be like that you don't
need to like you know try and solve The
World's Pro like no just sell your chips
I know it's just it's just like be funny
or creative I think like now the goal
for Brands is like either to have the
most celebrities per capita like just in
your commercial or you need to make us
cry and it's like why just be funny and
like sell your product or they just have
like so many boxes they're trying to
check yeah just like make the chips look
tasty no no and like do it in a funny
way it doesn't have to be funny it could
just be like smart smart tasty whatever
and if you want to have a celebrity
short but it's like literally the every
frame it's like wait it's The Tick
tocker oh now it's the pro athlete like
enough yeah and you know what I feel
like so many Brands when they invest in
Lay people Jake from State Farm uh-huh
flow so true Allstate I think that guy
is literally America's sweetheart Gekko
the Gekko I mean he's not even a person
these are iconic things as opposed to
just like another somebody who's gonna
sell himself for something else next
year you know what's a great commercial
that like
it's
been around for a while now that has
different versions that I first thought
it was annoying but now I think it's
funny
I think it's State Farm or Progressive
Progressive helps you stop you from
becoming your parents and they've like
the dads going into Lowe's you know yeah
yeah it's cute I like that one yeah
we've got a lot to offer
are we lay people in that sense well
we're like we're like you know standing
on the border between lay people and
z-list
we're a sleigh we're slay people yeah
that's so true are you ready for our
next story some legal news oh yeah
Tom gerardi has been indicted for
allegedly embezzling more than 15
million dollars from clients a grand
jury has more
it's hard to nail down so like I'm I'm
they found 15. okay a grand jury has
indicted time majority for allegedly
embezzling more than 15 million dollars
from his clients the Department of
Justice announced Wednesday the
disgraced attorney was charged with five
counts of wire fraud according to a copy
of the indictment and pertained by Page
Six Girardi and Christopher kazua kamin
the former controller and Chief
Financial Officer of the law firm
gerardi Keith or accused of lying to
their clients in order to misappropriate
settlement funds the attorney and his
former CFO allegedly use the clients
winnings to fund payroll other clients
settlement funds that have previously
been misappropriated and personal
expenses yikes I mean this does feel
like a moot point because we know Tom is
not he wasn't charged yet what have we
been talking about no and right I feel
like Erica was charged but Tom is also
not fit to sand trial so like I don't
think any of this
perhaps the other person but not Tom
yeah he's like in a living facility he
has dementia
he's like literally 90 pounds yeah
people like that no matter
conservatorship right like I think no
matter their crimes unless I feel like
the only people which I love who they
let you know stand trial are like
uh underground Nazis like they those
[__] still stand trial no matter how
frail they are but I feel like you know
especially for a financial crime it's
terrible yeah but I don't think this
will this has any legs our digestives
will be really served for Tom maybe the
other guy maybe the other guy and who's
keys
where is keys right was he involved or
did he really like not know and gerardi
like took I mean if we're going to say
Erica knew then Keith's [__] knew
touch a good point
such a good point peace with his name on
the door doesn't know where payroll is
coming from although I do you know now
really believe Erica did not know
yeah
yeah but you know no no no I hadn't
thought about my position in a while but
I I believe that is a very distinct
possibility as well yeah
yeah is plausible deniability yeah I
mean
Tom wouldn't even like let her like come
to work events with him she wasn't like
coming to the office and looking through
the books yeah it just like it
was a
I needed to come to terms with the fact
that their marriage wasn't what I
thought it was like I really all these
years and the way that she like
described it especially in her book like
really as much as of a marriage is equal
of equals as it could have been given
their situations and so it was more so
realizing like oh no she was just like
in a marriage with like a nasty old guy
yeah who was controlling and she made it
look like something that it wasn't right
correct so coming to terms with that
that's what I've been coming to terms of
I'm so glad you've been working on that
I didn't know you were working through
all of that yeah yeah I forgot that I
was working on that because because
you're constantly working on so many
things with the redheads the chickens
the chickens yeah and Beverly Hills
hasn't been out in a while so I forgot
where I stood but that is where it's
really crazy like I have and I know you
too like I don't watch Bravo
I will watch Beverly Hills I turned on
Real Housewives of Miami the other day
because I like I'm into it when I watch
it but I was watching too slowly like
too many pauses and they are still in
Key West and they're about to see a
shaman and there's just no way I'm
getting through that yeah I don't
actually don't really consider real
houses in Miami Bravo because it's on
peacock
um and like at one point like maybe I
will finish the season but like my life
no longer revolves around Salt Lake City
Potomac Beverly Hills New York I think
and it depends what I see when I when it
comes back but I might still watch
Beverly Hills but I'm done with
everything else yeah even though there's
like stuff going on in Potomac because I
like follow Housewives Twitter that like
actually seems interesting in the sense
that you know Robin Dixon who's tortured
us over the last few years with her
storyline being just like me and Juan
getting married me in one Affair me and
Juan this mean one that
um apparently she got married like off
camera and like surprised everyone it's
like oh we have to sit through the
Torches we don't even get to see the
wedding and then she made a patreon
episode talking about an affair that
Juan had and it's like that all seems
like interesting stuff for the reality
show that you're on you know if only we
got it's like that's like actually rude
like taking advantage of people's time
like that so people are really mad at
Robin
yeah
yeah I don't really know if I could get
interested no yeah no but I like I
that's like the extent of my knowledge I
have no idea what's going on people are
freaking about it but um I'm out I'm out
of the hamster wheel and it feels yes
that's exactly what it is a hamster I'm
free to do what I want
any old time I really am like it feels
good I don't even realize it
just gotten freeing and that was like
Ronnie Legacy probably not happening I'm
really free yeah our fifth and final
story are you ready it's a little more
reality TV show news though sure so
maybe you know you won't be free much
longer so true Sylvester Stallone's
reality show I'll be free the family
Stallone which is a good title yeah like
the Family Stone the family yeah yeah
we'll Premiere this spring on Paramount
plus oh out of this gave me like e-vibes
yeah but e doesn't invest in anything
anymore they're just like waiting for
someone to rescue them no e invests in
people for like a few months and then
you never hear about the show again yeah
Sylvester Stallone is gearing up to
share a whole new side of himself on
Thursday Paramount plus and announced
that the new eight-part docu-series the
family Stallone starring him and his
wife and his daughters will Premiere
this spring also his show that he's on
right now is on Paramount plus also
Tulsa King so he's just like a Paramount
plus king and I think he's in a Super
Bowl commercial for them cute I mean I
think this family is like ripe for
reality TV I don't know if we're like
still in the era of of family reality TV
shows like I don't know I kind of feel
like even with their Kardashians like I
don't I I didn't even finish the second
season like I do feel like format wise
this might be a little dated but I do
think this family is perfect for it it's
worth a shot for sure
um
and
I forget what else it reminds me of like
Bradshaw Bunch yeah like really pretty
cool kids and the recent drama about
like him and his wife getting divorced
and now they're not getting divorced
they're like they're they're well enough
to do a show together like no yeah it
makes me think it was like you know for
the no it kind of makes me think that no
I don't think so because like why would
we care
you know no no I don't think it was for
press
I don't know makes you think that I'm
sure they'll be discussing it on their
reality show but the daughter I love a
reality show that's now called the
docu-series I know like I love that
Rebrand yeah but the daughters are like
super cute they have a podcast they're
like young Hollywood girlies yeah so um
they're like close in age and they look
alike and that bodes well and there's
like
perfect for reality TV so I think it'll
be good yeah
um Choice do you want a reality show I
think kind of
if I could speak for him freely I think
he thinks you know the format is like a
little dated and he would like to do
something a little bit more you know New
Media New Age something that kind of
nobody else has done before like like a
podcast do you want a podcast if Bryce
had a podcast what would he say oh he
would talk about his passions which are
compassionate about a couple things that
have just they completely to overtake
his life he's passionate about
scratchies and the healing power of
scratchies and I know that's what he
would want to share with everyone yeah
and just maybe like he would travel to
different countries and show people the
power of scratching and how to scratch
past yeah yeah it's just like some
people he's like no offense like I love
my father but his nails are not too
short cut out she's like don't bother
yeah or maybe we could build like a
scratchy attachment right maybe like Joy
Mangano wants to get involved that's
such a joy Mankato product
literally I've been thinking about Joy
Mangano's you said her name yesterday
because of this book we read for the
redheads the Magnificent lives of
Marjorie post who's kind of like an
adventurous and just has like all of
these things that she's credited for
that we use in everyday life mostly food
Tings uh and that's so Joy so Joy what
is Joy up to what was the last Joy
product I'm sure she put one out
yesterday let's look it up no joy did
invent like the Slimline Hangar right
like the Velvet yeah no it's like
everything in your house like Joy what
was like the product from the film it
was a mop that you bring out that rung
itself it was like a self-reading mop
which she obviously didn't uh predict
swiffers sweepers coming no no because
that just but I still think like she
made Bank on the on the OG product oh
yeah yeah let's see she has a Miracle
Mop Huggable Hangers forever fragrant
home odor neutralizers uh close at all
luggage system
um
performance platforms a shoe comfort and
joy textiles Shades readers line of
reading glasses so now she's just like a
QVC Queen like making a lines of
everything but her first like and kind
of Hallmark invention was the
self-ringing mop yes yeah that movie's
so good it is so good did Jennifer
Lawrence win the Oscar for that like she
was incredible I don't think she did I
don't think she did either
that's like definitely some of her best
work she won for um Silver Linings which
was great too but I think Joy was better
yeah Joy's so good I didn't love Silver
Linings but you know I know you didn't I
liked it a lot so Random it was like a
movie about question mark but it was
cool
oh my God you're right yeah it was
actually like I think underlying like a
story about a man with a severe gambling
problem but like they never got into the
gambled the dad is a bookie Oh I thought
Bradley Cooper no sorry I don't think
the dad's the bookie the dad has a
bookie and like he literally is like
every Sunday betting and it's like we're
all focusing on like Bradley Cooper's
problems and he definitely has problems
the dance question mark yeah no the
movie's like a
definitely like a a hodgepodge of stuff
yeah like if you ask me like Claudio
what so actually I would love to see
what the one-liner about Silver Linings
Playbook I'll tell you what is the
description because it it's quite
literally a movie about nothing Silver
Linings Playbook on Google
after losing his job and wife and
spending time in a mental institution
Pat solitano winds up living with his
parents he wants to rebuild his life and
reunite with his wife but its parents
would be happy if he just shared their
obsession with the Philadelphia Eagles
things get complicated when Pat meets
Tiffany who offers to help him reconnect
with his wife if he will do something
very important for her in exchange I
mean that does look really sum up what
the movie's about but again it doesn't
say like what this movie is about right
and what's like the moral of the story
what's the the moral of the story is
sometimes what you're looking for is
right in front of you yes that's what
the moral of that story is a good moral
like all he wanted was like his wife
because he wanted like family and
stability but and love but he literally
had that with Jennifer Lawrence and in
his own home but he was just like too
obsessed with his ex-wife to see it yeah
that's what the movie's about I think it
was a book first I could see that being
like a better plot for a book where like
nothing happens that's not what Rome was
about we sat down for a movie I want a
real movie yeah and that's why you
should watch Joy yeah to bring the point
back home for some Joy
um well what's so delightful about
today's episode is that it's far from
over we have coming up next our
interview with Taylor Lautner I hope you
guys enjoy it and his wife Taylor the
Taylor Lautner is they're both named
Taylor
um I hope you enjoy it it's you know if
you're try hard you're really gonna love
it and it is brought to you by canopy
for a long time I've been using a
humidifier for my skin my sleep and my
overall Wellness but the problem is that
traditional models are notorious for
being ugly and impossible to maintain
let's talk about that well I was married
to a man who would literally he's
obsessed with humidifiers I didn't
really get it and he would pick up the
ugliest ones from the side of the road
but the uglier the better they make
they're disgusting they get moldy they
make like the weirdest sounds at night
and they don't actually do like work and
so I was like against humidifiers like
Ben used to want to bring one with us
when we traveled I'm like no they're
it's literally placebo
and then I got the canopy one I think I
was influenced the first time I got it
from Lauren Bostic and I understood like
the hype around and I didn't even
realize like my whole life I've been
waking up with like the driest nose like
this like sore throat because like there
was no moisture in my esophageal area
um and the canopy humidifier is game
changing so it's recommended by Leading
dermatologists the canopy humidifier is
a completely reimagined humidifier that
elevates your home for the ultimate in
skin care and wellness benefits they're
unique features and design make it the
easiest cleanest humidifier out there
and it is truly healthy Skin's best kept
secret it's also not busted looking like
it's nice like you can leave it on your
nightstand and it looks just like a nice
you know Vibe for your home it
contributes to the feng shui they have a
clean no Miss moisture that ever sleep
effortlessly hydrates your skin to
combat dryness dullness and fine lines
and wrinkles it's hassle-free technology
inhibits mold growth and the parts go
right in the dishwasher it's that easy
it shouldn't be that hard to clean your
humidifier and canopy understands that
throwing it in the dishwasher genius I
feel like after a week of these like old
crusty humidifiers it would turn like
brown and green it's so gross and then
it's like actively working against you
so if you want to get a canopy which we
highly recommend go to getcanopy.co to
save 25 on your canopy humidifier
purchase today with canopy's Filter
subscription so even better you can use
code toast at checkout to save an
additional 10 off your canopy purchase
your skin will thank you so that was
today's episode we hope you enjoyed it
but it's not over yet stay tuned for our
interview with Taylor Lautner from
Twilight and his wife Taylor Lautner she
is a nurse she's adorable and you guys
will really enjoy the interview so
thanks for listening to the show today
we'll see you tomorrow for Friday but
enjoy the enjoy the interview girls love
you bye
welcome back to the toast I am quaking
I'm so excited for today's guests it is
going to be a little confusing because I
am sitting down with Taylor Lautner and
I'm also sitting down with Taylor
Lautner welcome Taylor Lautner thank you
so much for being here thank you for
having us I feel like that's a perfect
segue into my first question for you
guys is having the same name you just
got married yes I told you this I feel
like every time I see it I'm like I have
friends named Taylor who also are
married but they didn't change it but I
do and they chose not to change their
names but you guys went for it I did
let's talk about that we did go for it I
I we've talked about it a lot before we
got married but I I was just like I what
do you want to do and she's like I don't
know and then I was like well I whatever
you want to do I'm fine with and she's
like well I mean before I met you I was
always planning right yeah taking
whoever I married's last name so I don't
know why it would change that that's
fair I mean we know why it would be yeah
but and so when when you did the hard
launch on Instagram I was shook because
I was like how are we gonna do this the
username Taylor Lautner already is taken
yeah so you have a tail launder and I
think for this the purpose of this
interview just to keep things Cut and
Clear I will be calling you today Tay
and Taylor yeah we also do Boyte girl
Tay if that oh that's cute I just
started with like Tay and Taylor because
we thought that would like simplify
things and honestly all of our friends
just started calling us Boyte and girl
that actually is super super cool but
you guys don't have nicknames like my
other friends Taylor and Taylor who I
told you about uh one of them goes by
Teddy Teddy yeah which is helpful okay
no well before we were married I went by
Tatum and that was always but not that
we are yeah one that's I do also like
consider you to dome yeah like just
because Instagram is like my life yeah
I'm gonna call you tato I don't know if
that'll ever change yeah do you miss
your last name
I think parts of it yeah maybe I missed
it I guess your last name yeah it's a
great last name yeah but I mean I feel
like it doesn't feel that weird saying
my new name because it's his name
because it already because I've been
saying that name yeah so it doesn't
really mean that name for five years
yeah and now it's just weird referring
to it as yourself I know it is and it's
also like the legacy of Taylor Lautner
like you're taking on a big name I am
and I know you're like a Twilight girly
which is like really why we connected
we also connected because we were both
on the right side of History being Team
Edward yeah and I wanted to ask you
Taylor like how that feels like even
your wife the person who's supposed to
love you most in this world was Team
Edward yeah
see I'm fine with it because one
I feel like I've converted her oh you
know what I think you did yes yeah but
if I'm being honest so I I hadn't seen
the movies in like this is a scoop right
now I've never said this and I feel like
I'm gonna get like a little bit of hate
okay I'll always have Jacob's back 100
but I haven't seen the movies or I
hadn't in like almost 10 years and it
was like a year ago and we were in a
hotel it was actually I was getting off
of work and I was coming out from the
hospital and he was in the hotel room
watching Twilight by himself the fact
that you would like have that experience
without me is actually hurtful but
continue I'll invite you over next time
please it was one of like the E like
they replay it all the time literally
five of them in a row yeah and I was so
bored of this yeah clearly she's at work
I'm like what am I gonna do and I was
scrolling through and like new moon was
on and I was like yeah why not I haven't
seen it in like 10 years oh my God and I
watched like new moon eclipse and maybe
like the first half of the first
Breaking Dawn or back to back just in
bed by myself iconic and as I was
watching it I was like
Jacob's a little Annoying a little
problematic I I love Jacob and his heart
but he's a little annoying okay you know
what like we stand growth and yeah and
evolution and that's huge of you to say
yeah thank you I appreciate that no
thank you my heart is beating out of my
chest right you know what I really I
can't even
um like put into words like the impact
Twilight actually had on me like I
always tell everyone I'm like a twyheart
and I mean it in like a serious way like
I think those were some of the best
movies ever made and like when I tell
you like brought me and my family
together I mean my sisters loved it like
it really was it was ever it still is
like it is everything it was so good and
I'm and I'm curious if like the
discourse like nationally being like
Team Edward Team Jacob like affected you
at all because like it's like toxic
masculinity thing like putting two
people against each other I'm sure you
guys actually were friends at the time
like did that get to you at all
um I feel like I'd be lying if I said no
right it's yeah I don't and I was so
young like I was I was 16 when Twilight
came out 17 for New Moon and Eclipse
um I finished the franchise by the time
I was 19. that's so crazy so yeah I was
so young and yeah I do feel like it was
very strange
um you know traveling the world and
being different cities and having like
thousands of screaming fans either take
your side or the other guy's side right
and like or a team yeah like we're both
just trying to make the best you know
movies but it yeah it was a little
bizarre the like competitiveness and
there wasn't a competitiveness between
in real life but having that constant
reminder
definitely it's toxic yeah I think it
definitely had an impact and I know you
guys are really into to mental health
and like vocal about it and I'm curious
because I feel like a lot of that comes
from you Tay girl Tay were you as in
tune with your mental health before you
met your wife absolutely not really no
um I feel like she she like took it out
of me that's so nice like I I think I
was dealing with stuff that I couldn't
even put my finger on like I didn't even
know why and then I think it took you
know meeting Tay and us just having
great intentional conversation together
um both ways
but having a safe place where
um you know I felt okay being like yeah
you know what it was tough I'm not okay
yeah I probably am dealing with some
stuff that started when I was 16 years
old yeah and now I'm 30 and still
haven't really addressed it dealt with
it yeah so yeah I'm very thankful for
that that's awesome how did you guys
meet his sister oh love that tell me
more yeah
um a mutual friend
um
my best friend and a girl that she went
to school with the same person
um I met Taylor's sister through her and
I think I met her like twice
um and after the second time she called
Taylor and was like hey you need to
throw game night I have a girl for you
oh I want to bring her over
and I mean I orchestrated this game I
love that my sister came and brought
like five or six of her friends who was
like organic and I had no clue that
there was a set up yeah that's kind of
the best way to go into it yeah nothing
to lose yeah yes agree for her number it
took her forever
Taylor Taylor's like the sweetest human
ever and I though I say like him hitting
on me I didn't know he was like hitting
on me
it's so nice like just normal well also
because I feel like just like guys
nowadays are just so like right and the
elephant in the room is like you're this
Larger than Life personality we grew up
watching you how do you navigate that
yeah I mean I wish I was better at it
I'm just awful at like I mean it worked
out yeah it's maybe you're not that bad
but did you know it took like a good
month in multiple Hangouts for her to
even realize that you were trying like I
like I asked for her number and like I'm
texting her in this whole time I'm
texting her every day she thinks I'm
just wanting to chat with my sister's
friend my sister's six years younger
than me right
um so it yeah it took it took some work
but we got there and you guys just got
married right how long has it been
uh
almost three months it was two months
now by the time the series right right
yeah what was the wedding planning
process like like me and Jackie speak on
the podcast all the time how it was
genuinely one of the worst times of My
Life
um did you guys have a similar
experience or no
um at times we had hiccups for sure
definitely had some bumps in the road
yeah we
I feel like us being like both of us
being very involved made it like better
and sometimes worse but we like the same
things we knew we wanted the same thing
we didn't disagree on anything it just
was like and we we love our wedding
planner he was phenomenal yeah but like
we also like know what we want so I
think the three of us just being very
involved is helpful yeah it was good and
sometimes too many cooks in the kitchen
right yeah there's also times where I
was like like I just didn't care like
the biggest thing
I knew I wanted like flat like I love
flowers me too oh yeah I knew like I
wanted that but I knew the colors I
wanted but no barzilla no our wedding
planner would bring up something I'd be
like nah whatever you think right right
you guys are so chill
couldn't be me I would hope so yeah yeah
we'll go chill with that and so can we
talk about your background a little
because I feel like I wouldn't if I'd
met known you both separately I would
never have paired you together you come
from totally different backgrounds yeah
you grew up in California correct but
not in the way that you grew up in
California Yeah Boy Taylor like you were
very much acting from the time you were
what 11.
technically eight I started when I lived
in Michigan and I was eight at the time
moved to LA when I was 11. and you
really like wanted it that was like what
your passion was I didn't see it coming
um I was like I grew up just playing
like every sport possible and I mean the
main thing I did was extreme martial
arts really yeah that's how we can flip
oh right Jacob was always doing the most
oh yeah yeah the most
um yeah so I that was my life from like
five until 13 14 was like just once a
month traveling the country sometimes
world for tournaments
um and it was my karate instructor who
lived here in La was actually the blue
Power Ranger Wow and he was like I think
you should like give acting a shot I
think you'd be good and for a while I
was like I don't know about that and he
finally convinced me uh and my family to
come out during a summer go on some
auditions see if I like it we stayed
with him very sweet
um he got me an agent wow and uh yeah I
I didn't book anything for that whole
summer I got a couple call backs and I
was like this is fun went back home to
Michigan my parents were like what do
you want to do I was like I want to do
this and they were super supportive
fairy wow yeah so they were like okay
well if you want to do it you know we
probably have to move to LA we can't
really because we actually for almost
two years did it from Michigan oh that's
tough yeah it was really rough I can
only imagine on them right so yeah we
eventually made the move and very yeah
very supportive family and how long
before like how long were you here
before things started to take off like
Sharkboy and Lava Girl was the biggest
kind of crazy that was the first big
thing and that was own it was less than
a year before we wow yeah or after we
moved out I know it was and everything
changed after that
kind of you know
it kind of came in waves for me like I
did Sharkboy and then right after that I
did Cheaper by the Dozen too
um I think I was like 14 when I did that
such a good movie very good movie
literally like nobody talks about how
that is those two movies are some of the
best movies ever made I could watch that
movie and star studded my God Steve
Martin Hillary Dove I know Eugene Levy
like Eugene Levy yes I know it's so good
um so then after that
I kind of hit like a a dry spell and I I
was going to public school the whole
time so I was going to high school on
the football team and a few years went
by where I just couldn't get anything
and I was like maybe that was the run
for me Sharkboy we like sad like as a
kid but during that period i i
think a bit I think a little bit of like
Oh I thought things were like going up
right I was 12 years old playing a
superhero right you got like a break and
you think after that it's all easy and
now I'm getting like crumbled papers
thrown at me in the back of the head
right during geometry oh
um so I think it was a little defeating
um yeah and then and then the Twilight
audition came up the best day of my life
for sure
and then tell me about your background
so you grew up totally different part of
California
um actually ironically the same
literally the same city we moved out to
like my hometown oh my that's so Kismet
I love that yeah very very rare hour and
a half outside of L.A but you didn't
know each other no we didn't yeah but
then she she got to know or not like
personally but she knew of my sister
there were only one year apart we went
to like rival high schools right
Facebook you know you know who the other
is I like say hi to her but yeah we
weren't friends yeah yeah and that's
kind of how that started yeah but grew
up very normal regular girl middle class
family just chilling I danced my whole
life that was that but yeah I never like
experience the industry aside from like
the creepy guys that come up to you at
the mall that say you should get the
major you're a model or whatever that
was right that's so funny um but yeah no
that was very different upbringings and
so now that you have collided these two
very different lives I'm curious what
like how do you digest all that comes
with Taylor you know Taylor your husband
the guy who walks the dogs like does
hopefully the showers
um but there's this whole other life
that he has like yeah on the other side
and I'm curious like I don't know how do
you how does that become normal
you know that's a good question I feel
like science we
you know I always say that Taylor's just
like he's just like the most normal
person you are like life with him like
if you're sitting at dinner with him
you're not like he's not this like
not I was gonna say charismatic but like
you're not an eccentric like you don't
he doesn't like act any suck the air out
of the room you know like he's just like
he's my little like golden retriever
when I tell him he's just like he's the
nicest human like he's so normal like
you can stick him in anywhere and he's
in great
um but I mean it was definitely like an
adjustment like I think one of our first
dates like
we were getting back in the car and like
Paparazzi was shooting us and he like
puts the sun visor down and I was like
what are you doing right you have a
protocol yeah like he knows like he was
like this is what you do or like even on
our Mini Moon like we're out in the
water and he's like okay look for boats
they're gonna be taking photos sure
enough we're literally pointing at the
boat that he's like this could be a boat
you know so I feel like Paparazzi
culture is so toxic for people's mental
health especially if you like body image
issues it's awful so I cannot like I
cannot imagine
being thrown into it like within a
matter of weeks and I'm curious like
what that was like he handles it like a
pro really like I it's much worse on me
than her really yeah yeah I mean I'd say
I think it yeah I think it depends I
think the worst obviously the worst one
was after our wedding there was a
leak somehow for a wedding and
um that first look so it was the first
moment that I saw her right in the dress
she sees me like very emotional moment
and like that was we were like waiting
to post because we were doing this whole
feature with Vogue stunning by the way
um
um but
we woke up after the wedding like the
weekend went so great everything went
absolutely perfect like I literally
couldn't have asked for a better weekend
and we woke up like to that story into
those photos and it was like like sure
take photos at the grocery store like I
don't care I'll be in my sweats and
sweatshirt no makeup I I just don't I
don't care she never cares I never seen
her this upset I mean that's like a
deeply personal intimate moment yeah
when that's like a moment that I've like
dreamed about for so long
hot mess but
but yeah it's just that that was that's
probably been one of the biggest like
moments in our relationship that I've
been like well this sucks like yeah you
know first life yeah so did you give her
any sort of like intro like once you
guys started getting serious did you
have to like a talk about like just
certain things in your life that are not
normal but that are normal for you or
you just sort of let it happen like the
paparazziing okay Diane that's a really
good question did I I don't know if it
was like you know we're dating here's
the protocol like here's what's gonna
happen if we go out it was I mean
at the very beginning sometimes like
when we were out like we wouldn't like
hold hands right or like that was like
right in towards the beginning but
we I mean we didn't post but we like
came out publicly hard launch yeah hard
launch
did I like be like okay like this is
some of the kind of stuff that happened
I feel like I just kind of let it happen
naturally and when something happened
just be like
yeah that's yeah or if we're going into
a situation and be like like if we're
going to like a party or do we have a
show or to like but before we did like a
carpet you'd be like this is the rundown
right so what'd you wear on your first
carpet
um this really pretty purple dress I
couldn't tell you but I can't remember
were you nervous
what was I I don't she also doesn't get
nervous like Built For This Life girl
like yeah we gotta get you in movies
yeah I grew up dancing it'd throw me on
a stage I'll talk in front of people and
I'm fine like that's like that's
comfortable to me
um small even though I do love
intentional conversations small groups
where I have to like that is harder for
me than like being in front of people I
completely agree like a smaller room of
like familiar faces I'd rather do it in
front of 50 000 people throw you on on a
stage I actually completely agree I
totally agree like what's more Awkward
than talking to people you know like
kill me
um and then I'm curious if there was
another moment in your guys's
relationship where you had to sit down
and tell them you were Team Edward
yeah when did I tell you that you made a
tick tock that was so [__] funny like
it was the best thing I'd ever seen in
my life about how you married Jacob and
you are Team Edward win that Trend first
came out I was like oh my gosh I should
do this and I was like no I don't want
to be like rude to Taylor and then like
a couple months later he sent it to me
and he was like you should do this I was
like
now that you have it there's my
permission yeah done that was so so
funny it was gold and now you guys are
kind of encroaching on my territory
you're launching a podcast but it's cool
we welcome all podcasters here at your
media and the toast
um but you actually told me over dinner
the other night that you just did your
first podcast yeah interview yeah I
literally did my first podcast is this
your second this is my second so you
gave someone else the exclusive
cool no I just it's good to know where
your friendships are at you know take
the temperature of all your friends wow
I thought we were close
[Music]
um yeah well I'm super honored that
you're my second me too and thank you if
I can't be first what happened I guess
I'll be second yeah second the best so
why podcast and I love the name so you
started you have such an interesting
background you became a nurse right when
the pandemic started like amazing timing
love that for you
um and you're really passionate about
mental health yeah and you started a
foundation like walk me through the
whole journey of from when you started
to become a nurse which you are no
longer a practicing nurse take me
through that yeah yeah well mental
health had always been like a part of my
life but never personally affected me I
had like family members struggle with
addiction and I almost lost the cousin
to heroin overdose twice
um I lost a good friend uh After High
School to
but he had bipolar he took his life and
that uh there was a lot of things that
had shaped me but never personally so I
started working as a nurse during covid
I'm like oh okay like
this is gonna be all right and then like
once once we actually like started
working I was like what what is
happening right now
um and there was just so many I started
working night shift
um I did like half night shift and then
I switched to days but
it was just the constant cycle of like
being understaffed
increasing our patient intake so instead
of four patients I had five I was a new
grad on my own having like to run into
each room put all the PPE on the goggles
The Shield the Gown the double gloves
The Masks
um go into one room care for one patient
run out take it all off re put it all
back on to go into the Next Room do that
without a Charged nurse who is like the
person who was like Hey you need help
putting a this in or doing this right
like you're so new yeah that's the
person that like helps you and guides
the floor they had to go into our like
monitor room because I worked on a
cardiac floor
um they had to go watch all the heart
monitors because our patients needed
more monitoring so it was just a
constant cycle of that or going into
work at 2AM to take vitals because we
didn't have enough staff for the nurses
to take it
um and nursing culture is very much like
people's lives are on the line yeah it's
so serious stuff so you just do you
don't really ask you just do and you
don't look like I literally would hold
my pee for eight hours you know like
there's just no that you don't you don't
eat during your shift sometimes like you
don't question it you just do it so
there was a cycle of that
um and after a few months Taylor we were
driving somewhere and he was like hey
are you okay and I was like yeah I'm
just like really tired I just worked
three nights in a row whatever it was
um he was like no but like actually are
you okay
when the conversation just like ended we
didn't like talk about it anymore and
that was really the first time I was
like oh am I like am I struggling or
something like how am I doing
um and it definitely took me a few
months to kind of process that because
also you can't process when you're in
that high-end environment it's also not
normal it was like this historic thing
that you were at the center of and you
were so new I don't even think like the
most trained nurse was prepared for what
they saw yeah they don't really teach
you that in nursing right so yeah
definitely took some time but I ended up
uh getting coveted really bad not from
work ironically but um I ended up
getting
sick really bad in like June of well now
I guess not last year 2021
um
and you were out for like two and a half
months yeah knocked me on my butt oh
damn yeah um which was just kind of
crazy but I think that was just kind of
like God the universe being like you
need a break yeah like you need to sit
down I'm not good I'm always constantly
doing something
it was like you need to chill you need
to take a look at yourself figure this
stuff out because like you're not doing
well dude what's best for you yeah so
during that I was able to kind of be
like okay I need to leave the hospital
this is not good for me like I'm not
this isn't where I'm supposed to be
um so I ended up leaving and after that
I was like what do I want to do like I
know I have this platform
um on social media I really like helping
people clearly I'm a nurse like that
helping people is something you're yeah
it brings me joy yeah so I was like what
do I want to do so I started this little
blog thing called lemons by Tay and I
was just like I'll write blogs on here
I'll share
I don't know thoughts feelings that I
have some tips and whatever that helped
me uh and then from there that kind of
morphed into a non-profit which I didn't
really have an intention of starting but
I woke up one day and I was like hey
babe I'm gonna start a non-profit he was
like what I was like yep he's like cool
so I started the lemons Foundation which
is a non-profit and then
a few months later I was like hey I
think I want to start a podcast yeah and
he was like what entrepreneurial Queen
We love to see them yeah so yeah that's
kind of like how we got to here and it's
it's definitely and you're hosting it
together yeah are you nervous at all
about working with a spouse it can it
could take a toll
you know I don't speak from experience
now
um we actually filmed our first episode
yesterday
um and you're still happily married yeah
no it went really well good the first
yeah the first two episodes are gonna be
me interviewing her and then her
interviewing me just so we can start it
off with right based on the horror story
of mental health and why we're doing
this podcast and then you know we'll
have awesome guests after that but um
yeah no I got to interview her and it
was a fantastic conversation and I'm
super excited for people to see it what
is your journey with mental health I
mean obviously Fame is toxic but you
were at like another level and you were
16. yeah I mean I think that's it I
think it's just
how unorthodox it was to grow up like
that and my journey is I'm in the middle
of it I'm still figuring it out I don't
you know she's like helped me but I'm
still very much in the process of you
know figuring out what all those things
I went through and how they affect me
today and how I you know go about life
now in the healthiest way
um but yeah I think it was a strange
upbringing so many incredible things of
course come with it I'm so thankful for
and you know wouldn't trade a thing but
yeah there's definitely there's no
handbook to no doing it yeah no handbook
to diving in as a coven nurse and right
handbook to
being a werewolf let me ask you a
question this is my time did you and do
you like being famous
yes and no okay that's so fair I like
some of the things that come with it
because we get to do super fun things
and feel very blessed because of that
but yeah there's definitely
sometimes I wish I could just go to the
grocery store and not have to wear a hat
and sunglasses right sometimes we do
just want to go to dinner and have a
peaceful dinner yeah so I think there's
you know like anything there's pros and
cons and what's your take on acting now
like do you is it something you really
want to continue to pursue
consistently I think my take is that
I am very lucky and blessed from the
franchise that I don't have to be
working all the time back to back
um because that creates that toxic cycle
of like needing projects to work so much
energy and like validation into getting
the role and that's that's the goal
that's where I want to be is I don't
have to feel and put this pressure on
myself that I haven't done a movie or TV
show in six months like what am I doing
right I'm failing right I don't want to
feel like that and I I don't
um yeah I I want to get to a place which
I think I'm I think I'm there
um where it's like if a project comes up
that it's a role I'm super passionate
about or it's somebody that I really
want to work with or I just think it'll
be super fun or it'll like just help me
grow like whatever it is I just want to
be able to wait for that opportunity and
be like yeah this sounds like it would
you know
further me right either like emotionally
yeah it's not all about what role you
look next and that's obviously a
privilege to be in that position but I
think it's super helpful when it comes
to your mental health because acting can
be so
so toxic when like you the rejection
it's it's not a normal way you're not
supposed to feel rejected in your job
every single day yeah but that's a huge
part of it yeah it's a rough it's a
rough business in that sense but you
know let me tell you about the business
of podcasting you guys you're gonna love
it you're gonna love it it's so fun you
can edit yourself like if you [__] up
it's just everything you can like set up
your own cameras make sure you like the
angle so I'm really honored to have had
you on the podcast and also to welcome
you into the podcasting space
um the podcast is called The Squeeze
which by the way actually one one more
question is what's with the lemons
lemons by the lemon Foundation The
Squeeze I love the name of the podcast
but what's the symbol symbolization
um you know symbolism sorry duh
I
I that's a good question I literally
when I was trying to think of a name for
the blog I like so I still have the
paper in my notebook I wrote down like
12 different names I could use and
lemons came to mind and I was like oh I
kind of like that because I've been
life's been literally chucking Lemons at
me right where I'm at right now so I
definitely think it's kind of like a fun
like plan that's a good reason I like
that lemons also lemons like are fresh
and healthy and like I don't know yeah
yellow is a happy color 100 I love your
tagline though of like
what like what when life gives you
lemons what do you do no I mean that's
cute but the like it feels as of
recently or over the last couple years
that you know we haven't been handed to
lemons right forcefully thrown at all of
us it's like what do you do with that
right it's not like here's a lemon it's
literally just right it's like that out
of control feeling take this yeah and
make it into something yummy and
beautiful right
um which we all can do but it's like
difficult it's yeah easy yeah and then
yeah with the podcast like I love when
you say like the lemon is like the juice
of your mental health so the squeeze
like yeah we want to get like into the
juice and just like from a branding
perspective like the squeeze sounds like
the name of a very very famous talk show
it's such a good name I agree I wish I
thought of it first the toast a lot to
do
um thank you guys so much for being here
I love hanging out with you thank you
guys for listening I hope you enjoyed
this episode make sure to check out the
squeeze podcast it is now streaming
everywhere you get your podcast correct
yes ma'am correct thank you guys for
listening hope you have an amazing day
uh take care of your mental health and
like do a face mask and then go take a
tequila shot love you bye